tenter de reprendre le dialogue avec
l'espoir d'une réunification des
discussions informelles commence ce
mardi à genève sous l'égide de l'onu
entre les dirigeants de deux partis
irréconciliables depuis 47 ans l'île est
divisée depuis 1974
la turquie avait envahi la partie nord
du pays
en réaction à un coup d'état visant à
rattacher l'île à la grèce
désormais il y a d'un côté la république
de chypre membre de l'union européenne
reconnue par l'onu est majoritairement
peuplé de chypriotes grecs de l'autre
l'autoproclamé république turque de
chypre du nord uniquement reconnue par
la turquie est depuis toutes les
tentatives de réunification ont échoué
les discussions de ce mardi sont les
premières depuis quatre ans nous allons
à genève fermement décidé à reprendre
les négociations pour réunifier chypre
sous la forme d'une fédération
bicommunautaire et bizonale conformément
aux résolutions de l'onu
côté chypriote turque on est plus
prudent sur un aboutissement des
discussions les dirigeants sont moins
optimistes face à une perspective de
réunification
il ne peut y avoir de terrain d'entente
tant que nous sommes traitées de manière
inégale comme nous l'avons été toutes
ces années c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas
eu de terrain d'entente dans le passé
nous sommes toujours traitées de manière
illégale
ils sont l'état nous sommes prêts
semblablement la communauté donc nous ne
sommes pas égoïstes la république turque
de chypre du nord est une zone
stratégique majeur pour la turquie et
pour son influence en mer méditerranée
le président turc recep tayyip erdogan
est présent à genève tout comme les
représentants de la grèce et du royaume
uni les deux autres garant de l'île
depuis son indépendance en 1960